(audience clapping)
- Oh my gosh.
- What's up?
- I mean, with a last name, like Majors.
You got a military family,
this is incredible.
- Oh yeah.
- It's crazy.
- Yeah, how are you?
- I'm good. I feel like I should go
to the gym after hugging you.
Like when we hugged, I was like
this is like hugging Lester, my drummer.
It's like a-- just a brick wall man.
Yeah. Do you just work out all the time?
Don't say genetics. I'll slap you.
(audience laughing)
Don't you do it.
- I work out a lot.
(audience laughing)
- Thank you.
- And when I work out--
- You lie.
- When I work out
it feels like there's a
musical theme going on,
with the brothers up there.
Thank you all for your
service, first and foremost.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- And Kelly.
- Yeah.
- I would have you know,
that when I work out
- Oh, what's-?
- What is on my playlist.
- I wanna know. I love that, by the way.
- Since I was a boy.
- No, you did not just
pull up that record.
(Since U Been Gone by
Kelly Clarkson playing)
- You already now.
♪ Here's the thing, we
started out friends ♪
♪ It was cool, but it was all pretend ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
- You work out to this?
- This is me.
♪ Since you been gone ♪
(audience cheering)
♪ You're dedicated, you took the time ♪
- Just so you know, this is me.
♪ Yeah yeah ♪
- It's a great song. It's a great song.
It's a great song.
(audience cheering)
- Oh man. It's so funny that you say that.
Cause I hadn't done a show in forever
and I used to jump up and down.
I used to run all over the stage.
I was like crazy. And now I'm just like
Woo. Holding down this mic stand.
(audience laughing)
I love that you love that song.
I would've never guessed
that. It's amazing.
- [Jonathan] Love it.
- [Kelly] So what branch of the
military was your family in?
- Oh, wow. We were--
My father was in the Air Force.
(audience cheering)
My maternal grandfather was in the Army.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And my paternal
grandfather was in the Navy.
- Wow.
(audience cheering)
Covered all the bases. That's incredible.
- Yeah. Yeah. And I was hell
bent on joining the Marines.
- Yeah, you can, I hugged you.
- Tried to do it, but I missed that boat.
- Oh my gosh. So wait,
were your grandfathers
like a big influence on you growing up?
- A huge influence.
They were two very different men.
The Navy man was very quiet.
He would sit in this chair.
He was about six five and just kind of
Yeah, Grandson. Yeah,
Grandson. Yeah, Grandson.
And then my army grandfather
who I spent all my time
with him on a farm.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Was quite gregarious. But yeah.
- Also just personalities in general,
people handle things different.
- Oh yeah. They taught
me so much, you know?
Don't put your hands in your pocket.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Oh God.
- Ever. Yes sir. No, sir.
I had to get up early in the morning
feed the chickens or work out.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, just the
bearing of those two men
really set me, set me, set me straight.
- So we just saw a bit of
Jonathan's new movie Devotion.
That was intense.
Devotion is based on a true story.
Do you do you appreciate doing
true stories rather than fiction?
- Making movies is probably
one of the most exciting
things in the world.
- Just for some.
- [Jonathan] For some.
- Sounds like Hell to others.
- Copy that. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, for me. But telling a true story
gives a certain amount of stakes.
- Yeah. Weight to it.
- Yeah. Yeah. And you, I like high stakes.
- Yeah.
- So this story, in particular
did have a great deal of pressure
primarily because, you know, as I said
my grandfathers were in the service.
And my paternal grandfather,
the guy who, you know
ran the farm, built
the farm, was in Korea.
And this story is about the Korean War.
About the first black naval aviator.
And he fought in the Korean War.
His name was Ensign Jesse Leroy Brown.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, there he is. Handsome cat.
And you know, as you
all know, unfortunately
that war is labeled the forgotten war.
And this is only the second
major motion picture made
that captures that story.
And for me, talking
about pressure and stakes
to bring that story and
to tell a small glimpse
of that war and those, you know, soldiers
- And to honor them.
- Yeah. And to honor them
on such a grand stage was
extremely high pressure
and a huge honor.
And we did the best we could.
And I think it's pretty great.
- Oh my God, that's so cool too.
(audience clapping)
Like just the relation, like
with your grandfather having been in it.
That's so cool.
- Big time. Big time. Big time.
- Yeah. So did you, did
any pilots take you up
for like a lesson or anything,
or show you anything?
- Woo! Did they.
- I flew with the Blue Angels once.
- Did you?
- I did.
- Funny, funny, funny,
funny, funny, funny segue.
Our director, JD Dillard, his father
was the second black Blue Angel
in the history of the Blue Angels.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah. And so we--
- That's incredible.
- Talk about stakes, man.
We were making this
movie with like, so much
so much pressure and so much support.
You know, we had guys we
could talk to and say,
Hey, what was this like?
And they'd say, It's like
this. You know what I mean?
And I learned in that
plane what it was like.
- Yeah.
- To a minimal degree.
But it was pretty intense.
Oh yeah. That's my man.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Yeah.
- No, I'll tell you, it is intense.
I did well, like the first part.
And then all of a sudden he was like
you're doing so well. You
want me to do a trick?
I was like, Hell Yeah. I was
like singing the Top Gun theme.
I was like--
- Yeah, yeah.
- I was just whatever, stupid.
And then I proceeded
to completely black out
and barf everywhere after the trick.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Cause because he broke the
Gs you weren't supposed to.
- [Jonathan] Right.
- But I literally, there's
video of me going, Yeah.
- [Jonathan] Oh God, yeah yeah yeah.
- It's like crazy. And then--
- Well, the trick I learned--
- [Kelly] It's hard.
- Is bananas.
- What, what does that mean?
- [Jonathan] Bananas.
- You just eat bananas?
- Because they taste
the same way going down
as they do coming up.
- For the encore?
(Kelly laughing)
- Yeah, yeah. And I mean, yeah
we were doing barrel turns.
When you all see the film
and I hope you guys all
go out and check it out.
The opening sequence is
myself as Jesse Brown
and the beautiful Glen
Powell as Tom Huttner.
And we're on a run, a NAF hop.
NAF hop. Yeah? And we're rolling.
And there's a lighthouse.
And we go right by the lighthouse.
Then we're about 10,
20 feet off the ground
from the water and you're holding on.
And then they go
and push up.
And he was like, Do you want come down?
I said, No sir, I do not wanna come down.
And the truth of the
matter is in that moment
yeah I wanted to go down
(Kelly laughing)
but I was thinking about, truthfully
I was thinking about our servicemen.
I was thinking about Jesse.
- Yeah.
- And what he would've gone through.
And for me that's the best exercise
to get close to the character.
And Jesse Brown
as you guys will see in
the film, never quit.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And a part of me was
like, There's no way.
There's no way I'm going down.
- I love that you feel so inspired.
- You've gotta honor the character.
And he deserves it.
And that was a pretty
pretty gangster move.
- Dude. I know that it
is hard to hold it down
cause mama didn't.
- You didn't?
- No mama came back with like a pink bag
filled with my vomit.
(audience laughing)
But I have to talk about how you're a part
of the Marvel universe.
I love Marvel as well.
And I love the fact this juxtaposition
you playing such a serious, like cool
like historically relevant film
and then also getting
into the Marvel world,
which I love that world, too.
(audience clapping)
So it's just fun to kinda
exercise those different muscles.
And so you're Kang, right?
- [Jonathan] I am. I am.
- [Kelly] You're Kang?
- [Jonathan] I am Kang, yeah.
- Yes! We are like
Marvel people. We love--
I know. No, but I love that.
I love, my favorite thing is when,
and it's rare when someone comes on here
and you're doing something that
like I said, it's like
historically relevant.
It's really important, that kinda thing.
But then you do something super fun
and like just action packed.
I think it's awesome to do.
Do you like, I would
assume you don't wanna play
the same role over and
over. So it's kind of fun.
To play a villain?
- Yeah I mean- a villain. I'm sorry.
A super villain.
- He said super.
(audience clapping)
- That's amazing.
- It's extremely humbling, you know?
And a lot of fun.
And you know, I remember
sitting on the incubator
at my granddaddy's farm.
- Yeah.
- Reading all the books.
And my imagination would go
and I would, you know,
play in these worlds.
And I never imagined or
perhaps I always hoped
that I would be able to do that, you know?
- Yeah.
- Step in the worlds like that.
And again, Kang is
definitely a dream come true.
You know, for an actor.
- It's just fun to play a bad guy.
- Oh, it's the best.
- Yeah.
- It's the best. I mean--
- You get to be a jerk and
people love it and want it.
Who, when can you say that?
- Yeah, true, true, true.
And the more jerkish you
are, the more they love you.
- Oh my God. It's like more, Yeah.
- There's layers to it, you know?
- Yeah.
- There's layers.
- How you got there.
- Okay.
- To the jerk, you know.
- I'm gonna peel all of
them back when I watch it.
- Yes ma'am. Yes, ma'am.